وما هي في استوديو الزميل عمار الحميده
واهلا بك عمار بعد ضربات التركيه على شمال
العراق كيف تتعامل الحكومه العراقيه مع
الضربات الايرانيه
لهذه الضربات التي تكررت في ظرف اقل من
اسبوع هذه الضربه الثانيه التي تقوم بها
القوات الايرانيه او قوات تابعه للحرس
الثوري الايراني تستهدف مواقع تواجد
المعارضين الايرانيين وهما يتواجدون في
هذه المناطق من الثمانينات القرن الماضي
حسب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني وكذلك
تنظيم تواجدون في هذه المناطق وهي عباره
عن مخيمات للاجئين ومراكز لهذه الاحزاب
ايران تتهم هذه الاحزاب بالوقوف وموجه
التظاهرات المستمر في ايران منذ مقتل
الشاب الايرانيه همسه همم امين همم هذه
همم
الضربات تتعامل معها القوات الحكومه
العراقيه
همم خجوله لا يكون هنالك يعني رد فعل
عراقي بحزم بحجم هذا الخرق همم وهو خلق
لسياده العراق الكثير من العراقيين همم
عبروا عن استغرابهم من موقف الحكومه
العراقيه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي منذ
يوم امس الى الان لماذا هذا الغياب
للحكومه العراقيه لماذا لا يكون هناك شدب
وكذلك ربما قطع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع
ايران خاصه وان ايران تعتمد بشكل كبير
ايضا من الناحيه الاقتصاديه على سوق
العراقيه وهناك وسائل ضغط للحكومه
العراقيه ارادت ان تستخدمها لوقف هذا همم
يعني الاختراق همم الامني الخطير لسياده
العراق وهذا الانتهاك لسياده العراق لكن
الحكومه العراقيه حتى هذه اللحظه لم تقوم
بدور همم رد فعل يتوازي مع حجم هذا همم
تهديد وخلافه للولايات المتحده والمنظمه
همم الامم المتحده اللتان شجبتان هذا همم
الاعتداء مطالب ايضا اقليم كردستان من
اصدقاء اقليم كردستان بالوقوف جنب اقليم
كردستان امام هذا التهديد ايضا كثير كثير
من التساؤلات لماذا اقليم كردستان لا
يعتمد على موقف الحكومه العراقيه اذن هذه
الضربات تثير الكثير من التساؤلات عن همم
صلابه موقف الحكومه العراقيه اتجاه مواقف
ايران المعاديه لي سياده العراق في الاونه
الاخيره شكرا جزيلا لك يا عمار